le socle où je trouvais la statue de
Johnny McDonald au centre ville de
Montréal pourrait bien demeurer vide
après tout
durant une manifestation contre le
racisme et la brutalité policière en
2020 elle avait été déboulonnée puis
décapité
elle a ensuite été entreposé un comité
formé par la Ville de Montréal devait
déterminer son avenir
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec une statue que
des personnes un petit peu impatientes
comme ça ce comité dans un avis
préliminaire publié aujourd'hui exclut
la possibilité de remettre la statue de
Johnny McDonald en place tel qu'elle
était considérant les politiques
assimilatrices et génocidaires qui l'a
mise en oeuvre à l'endroit des peuples
autochtones écrit-on le Comité estime
dans l'esprit du processus de
réconciliation qu'il est nécessaire de
se distancer de cet héritage de Johnny
McDonald et de la vision coloniale
représentée par le monument il
recommande de laisser la structure en
place et de lui donner une nouvelle
signification
pourrait être associé à des
commémorations par exemple de la Journée
nationale de réconciliation on le voit
comme celui qui a
poursuivi de sa haine Muriel qui
à la patience c'est quelqu'un qui a été
le père de de l'exclusion des autocades
les monuments à l'effigie du premier
ministre du Canada ont provoqué la
controverse partout au pays la Ville de
Montréal n'est pas encore prête à faire
connaître ses intentions on accueille
toutes les recommandations qui ont été
faites puis on va aussi entendre les
montréalers à ce sujet je suis à mitigé
les citoyens de Montréal auront
l'occasion de se prononcer sur l'avenir
du monument à l'occasion d'une séance
d'études publiques tenues par la ville
dans deux semaines après quoi le comité
formulera ses recommandations finales
ici Sébastien Desrosiers Radio-Canada
Montréal